titanfall 2 has 10 custom pilot slots
and for a veteran shooter player that's
a lot of temptation to stay up late at
night crafting mode specific murder
machines and giving them dumb names not
that's something that I would do I do
not require your stuff but if it did
here are 5 loadouts you should try
number 1 the grunt farmer for bounty
hunt the name of the game is cash in the
bank it doesn't matter how much money is
in your pocket when another pilot can
take 50% of your earnings by simply
killing you that's where the grunt
farmer comes in to make tons of cash
fast and get out quick grab Electric
smoke grenades the devotion LMG with
threat scope + ordnance expert so you
got even more nades the smoke conceals
you and the threat scope lets you peek
through it allowing you to murder all
comers without being seen this technique
can be used both at farming spots and at
the bank don't forget to bring scorch
along the most varmint is Titan of all
time you're welcome
number 2 the dimensional sneak abou the
only thing better than getting
metaphysical with phase shift is calling
and Ronin to share the fun roll with
Archer Nate's so you can keep your
targets right where you left them when
you exit the nether a phasing pilot can
cheat death while ejecting get to the
dropship more reliably hang out in black
and white while their Titan drops and
switch weapons all in the safety of a
completely not dubious other universe
plus you can blow pilots up from the
inside after earning the inner pieces
execution
splosh roll with extra battery to give
ronan a fighting chance while closing
distance and for the last laugh take
nuclear eject and let Ronan phase when
doomed
which gives enemy Titans a fraction of
the time to clear the blast radius
successfully do that and you get another
Titan number three the silent and deadly
despite fast movement titanfall 2 can be
a great game for long-range sniping
especially in pilot versus pilot mode
cloak makes you hard to spot at range or
it can make you banished from that pulse
blade ping and using a suppressed pistol
allow you to quietly remove pilots at
close range pro tip if you can find the
pulse blade you can actually destroy
that - and don't forget power cell to
let you click more often for the final
touch low profile will hide your jump
Jets
for Plan B always take a boost with you
like an anti infantry turret or a wall
to help you escape if you're caught in
half to boogie number for such an AWOL
hardpoint can be a game of sit and wait
so can other modes to enhance your
sitting and/or waiting capability as a
pilot not being shot helps a lot with
two impenetrable walls the a wall and
hard cover boost covers your nuts and
butts plus amps outgoing damage the only
other thing a pilot could ask for is a
legion with a Titan assault ship at his
or her side note this loadout may even
save you from a nuclear jet
and finally number five this Archer gets
high as frigate birds sometimes it's
heightened battle goes horribly wrong
and you find yourself out of your
favorite mechanical death machine in
that case on most Maps your job is to
get up high in rain Archer rockets on
the remaining enemy Titans nothing gets
a pilot higher than the grapple hook the
hover ability and the archer launcher
make sure to bring the anti Titan turret
boost with you so that even if you die
you may get the last laugh from beyond
the grave and those are my five favorite
pilot loadouts what are your dumb names
and great strategies in titanfall to let
us know in the comments below and for
more coverage of titanfall - stay tuned
to games.com
control